he's the fastest man in the world and
yet directors keep running away so I
came really close to doing kind of a
video review of the first trailer for
the new Suicide Squad a-and made a movie
but then I saw it and was neither angry
enough nor excited by it in any Pacific
way that I actually wanted to talk about
it and hey then I found this news so hey
I'll talk about this instead so the
flash movie has a director or directors
two of them which I mean it might as
well for how many else they burned
through already if government following
what's been going on with the flash
movie it has it's gone through a lot of
directors I think officially it's only
burned through to up to this point but
there were a lot of others who have been
attached in negotiations early
development and then bailed bail bailed
and we still don't know what the flash
movie is I think I mean last we heard it
was gonna be flashpoint I don't think
they've confirmed that in a while now
and and I've said before personally I I
hope it isn't because I don't think a
reboots necessary anymore but I mean we
we don't know what I'm not here talking
about that here to talk about the
directors now if you heard this news you
might have had the same initial reaction
I did because the way it's been reported
is a little unfair which is that it is
being directed by the two guys who
directed the vacation reboot you you
remember that right no yeah me neither
and you know you hear that you think of
God what is going on but the thing is
you need to look past that a little bit
more of their filmography and I think
you need to look more recent than that
to be specific first of all this is a
writing team they've only started
directing fairly recently but they've
been a writing team for a long time tend
to be leaning towards comedic ly styled
stuff they've got a newer movie coming
out called game night which the trailer
was decent for and from what I hear the
early screenings are actually quite
positive on that's not a guarantee of
anything but look I'm just saying but I
think most relevant to this is they
worked on the script for spider-man
homecoming which was really
good and I thought the script was really
good now of course they worked on the
early drafts which means they have story
by credits and it's harder to be certain
on knowing that it got revised by later
writers as it went on how much of what
they originally put in there actually
arrived translated to the screen and how
much of it were just the broad strokes
were kept so I don't want to over praise
them for their involvement with
spider-man homecoming but that to me is
a decent connection and I think one
that's particularly relevant because the
way flash was depicted in Justice League
the way Ezra Miller is playing him is
light is slightly comedic is a little
bit awkward is not too far off from how
they did Peter Parker and I'm not saying
that like do it the same copy that mom I
mean that what these guys worked on
previously that I think turned out very
well
featured a character that had some
comedic moments and was a little awkward
and was kind of new at this and yet
still ranked some good strong emotional
beats out of it which I would also hope
a flash movie could do and that's a good
mood tone approach I mean that the flash
should be light fun and I don't mean
like it can't be serious there have been
serious flash stories but like as a
character when a character's main thing
is speed you can't be slow you can't be
ponderous and honestly speed just lends
itself to comedy it lends itself to
slapstick and and you know while it's
possible to overplay that certainly
that's that's just an easy way to go
with it it's sort of it's what speed you
know high speed really lends itself to
so I think that's the right tone to try
to approach approach this character with
so I'm actually slightly more up on this
news that I think a lot of people that I
know seem to be because again the
headline was directors of vacation
directing the flash and you see then you
go and I mean if I'm being honest I'm I
don't want to say I'm positive on the DC
movies right now
because that's a step too far but I'm
I'm kind of pulling for them at this
point I want them to be good I want them
to be better and more to the point
unlike what I I'm like almost a year ago
when I did my very angry video screaming
at Warner Brothers that I wanted this
whole thing to die down again that had
more to do with Warner Brothers than it
did with the movies they were actually
making because they seem to be just
barreling ahead with this what I felt
was a very incorrect wrongheaded
misrepresentative of what these
characters are meant to be way of
telling these stories and now it looks
like they are trying to you know correct
that now are they trying to correct it
because we got it wrong and we have to
see more to see merit in this know
they're trying to fix their box office
because it hasn't been where they've
wanted it the last few these movies
except for Wonder Woman so I mean I
understand it's completely cynical but
they're still trying to move it more to
where I at least would like it to be so
I I'm kind of pulling for them I want
these to get better because I see that
they're trying to make them better now I
also want to just clarify something
before somebody yells at me you know
with the what do you mean lighten your
fluffy don't make DC into Marvel Kitty
movies with jokes look I'm not saying
apply this to every story that you're
gonna do in the DC EU I'm talking about
flash specifically and flash just
doesn't lend himself to that kind of
storytelling I'm not saying that we
should have the Brave and the bold
version of Batman in the Batman movie
that Matt Reeves is working on do Batman
dark cuz that's what Batman is good at
do flash light because that's what flash
is good at what I'm saying is here's a
crazy idea don't come up with the
uniform idea of how this entire universe
is going to look and feel in terms of
tone and characterization and maybe
tailor each individual franchise to the
strengths of the character wild notion I
know so I'm not sure I have too much
more to say on it but
is that but I just I feel like I needed
to put a slightly more optimistic voice
versus I think a lot of the snark that
I've kind of been seeing in regards to
this announcement now let's also put the
asterisk on here of this is all assuming
that they stick with the darn thing cuz
like I said directors on this movie it
they they've just been dropping like
flies it has been left and right and the
thing is though I suspect largely that
was probably tied to the fact that
Warner Brothers was really reluctant to
give up a release date on this and I
suspect they were putting directors
under extreme tight constraints and
weren't willing to move the release date
at this point that that I can't imagine
is the case anymore and there being much
more well much less rigid about saying
we will release whatever state it's in
it's getting released and I have a
feeling they're gonna I mean they don't
want to wait forever obviously but I
have I have a feeling they're gonna let
these guys or whoever else if these guys
Bale to take the time that they need
because I think hopefully Warner
Brothers has realized that a big part of
what got them into the mess that they
are in was how much they were barreling
ahead and rushing everything and I don't
just mean in terms of jumping to a
team-up movie with your second film and
the franchise I mean just how rushed the
schedule was the fact that they only
gave Suicide Squad six weeks to have the
script written the fact that they were
in pre-production on sequels to films
that they didn't even know if anybody
liked yet and you know and were too far
ahead in them to be able to change them
once they realized people didn't like
the preceding films I think they
realized that that kind of rushing that
they were doing was not helping was a
big part of the problem so ironically
enough they need to slow down on the
flash movie so yeah I think as far as
this kind of news can be it's decent
enough and I did enjoy Azra Miller in
Justice League so I'm game for this and
and I it's worth pointing out I usually
don't like Ezra Miller I find there's
some
inherently not likable about him to me
but he works for me in this so I props
there so I think that's about it
directors put on the flash again what
are your thoughts on this whatever they
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it do all that stuff
you know the things likes and subscribes
and stuff I got a Twitter and an email
and a patreon and I'm trying not to go
do crazy I'm plugging the patreon but I
just want to point out if I can get like
1/10 of 1% of my subscribers to pitch in
for a buck a month pledge I'll hit my
next goal I'm just saying
anyways links for all that stuff is down
below so until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]